earlier this year the university of
michigan acknowledged it was
investigating
sexual abuse and misconduct by a former
university doctor
who'd spent more than three decades at
the school one of hundreds of alleged
victims former michigan football player
chuck
christian is giving his first network
interview while pursuing a lawsuit
against the school
now a husband father and grandfather
christian is also dying
of prostate cancer he blames his late
diagnosis on the trauma he says
he suffered at the hands of his team
doctor
they found that i had prostate cancer
and that it was stage four
and it had spread to my spine my hips
my tailbone my shoulders
my ribs and that's why they would give
me three years to live
over four years ago doctors told chuck
christian he likely wouldn't make it
past his 60th birthday
we met him on the day he celebrated his
61st
happy birthday thank you thank you what
have your doctors said now they gave you
three years
you're beyond that now we're just going
to keep taking it one
one day at a time christian believes his
life is being cut
short because of his sheer terror when
it comes to doctors
a fear that dates back to his football
playing days at the university of
michigan in the 1970s
that's when he says he was molested by
the team
doctor robert anderson he did the
regular stuff
turn your head and cough turn your head
and cough then when he said
to um bend over and he put on the rubber
glove and snapped it
i'm like what is what is he doing and
then
when he inserted it it was painful and i
screamed
i screamed like a little like a little
baby
and he said he said to me he said you
feel pressure don't you i said
no i feel pain i know the difference
between pain
and pressure did you say something to
anyone right after the exam
yes i said something to one of my um new
friends that i haven't and he said
the same thing he's like yeah man i feel
violated when i talked to the
upperclassmen they said the same thing
they said yeah
he's going to do that to you for four
years i'm like oh god he says he
accepted it as a normal part of annual
physicals required to play college
football
i figured maybe this is just something i
have to deal with to be able to play
on the level of michigan football but
for decades he says he was scarred
avoiding doctors and tests at all costs
even when he was showing symptoms i was
about 45 and i started having problems
with my prostate
and the doctors put on the glove and
snapped it
and my brain just went zip right back to
anderson
and he said i want to do a digital exam
on you and i said no
no you're not going to do that to me and
how much longer did you go before you
finally had that exam
another 10 years 10 years he believes
too late i got like eight grandkids and
i'm like i want i want to
spend time with my grandkids and i i
don't know how much time i got
i really don't know it's just a lot it's
a lot to process
the university of michigan recently
acknowledged the sexual misconduct by dr
anderson and in february revealed
findings of an investigation
christian learned he was one of hundreds
of alleged victims
what did you think when you knew i
wasn't alone
there are other people that went through
this i felt like yeah i wasn't alone but
then i felt like
i felt like
michigan dropped the ball and when
when they came to my house and talked to
my mom they said
we're going to take care of your son
and they didn't they didn't protect us
and then when i found out later on that
don cannon knew
that anderson was doing things he was
athletic director
and he knew but he didn't do anything
about it he just let it happen
cannon and dr anderson have both since
died
christian is now suing the university
for accountability
claiming it failed to protect him when
he was a student
have you found closure at this point
what i did i learned to forgive
and i forgave anderson for what he did
to us
but i didn't forgive him for him i
forgave him for me
so that i can be free and that i can be
the granddad and the dad that i should
be
i'm not gonna let him ruin any more of
my life
and chuck christian's health since we
did that interview has deteriorated
well he knows he'll likely not see the
outcome from the lawsuit
he's hoping that by sharing the story he
can help put systems in place to prevent
other players from going through what he
did
a university of michigan spokesperson
told us it's conducting an independent
investigation into the allegations that
will allow it to better prevent abuse
from happening in the future
the university says it can't provide any
further comment though due to the
ongoing
litigation i'm obviously an alum of the
university i've gotten several letters
from them
they are reaching out asking anybody who
attended the school in that span
to say something if they were also an
alleged victim if something happened but
with chuck being so public as a football
player it had such an impact on other
people feeling the strength to come
forward
the key is systems in place yeah systems
to prevent
and this is not the only school that's
happened at ohio state also
and people are able to tell their
stories now because they feel like they
have
some power and hoping for accountability
that's going to make an impact
yeah it really will because somebody
took that first step